well did you see that tweet from uh was
virginia heffernan
from the la times earlier today talking
about the uh the
uh gun ownership for the 50 mile radius
no so she was saying
she was saying um i i think i guess she
was like buying a house or
just looking at this this issue she is
talking about she's totally ridiculous
she's the one who
had the the trump supporting neighbor
who was shoveling her lawn and she was
like
or shoveling her driveway like i don't
know if i should thank him
what should i say to this did he really
shovel my driveway is the snow
actually gone he didn't did he shovel it
out of hate i mean it was white snow
so you know and uh perhaps she's
building some sort of you know she's so
so no she had to tweet up today where
she was saying in real estate listings
they should this is la times columnist
used to work at wired
that they should um include
how many people own guns around you for
a 50 mile radius
and then um you know correct if i'm
getting any of this wrong
and then include a list of all the mass
shootings
that have taken place in conjunction now
obviously having a list of like owners
completely illegal
um but also like there are websites you
can look at for criminal reports
that's that's what i was saying i just i
just quote tweeted and i was like yeah
who wants to tell her because i'm
willing to bet that in some of the
lowest crime radiuses
of the united states there's a ton of
law-abiding gun owners yeah
we know it depends on the crime right so
out here there's a whole lot of drugs
sure okay it's it's like people's
strongholds i'm
guessing might be two might be reading
between the lines i'm pretty sure she
means violent crime
right right she she actually says uh gun
violence okay she says gun violence in
there yeah yeah actually i'm pretty sure
it's a lot safer out here uh i'd be more
worried about chicago
uh lots of gun laws and lots of people
shooting each other
like west virginia's constitutional
carry and people like i don't i hear
gunshots all the time
you know the the other day yeah
baltimore's not that far away though
well so something i explained a while
ago it's when i live in new york and i
hear gunshots that freaks me out right
because you're not supposed to also it's
a really dense urban area like what are
they shooting
right out here it's like i wake up and
there's gun i'm actually i wake up and
i'm kind of worried when there aren't
gunshots i'm like
the neighbor's not out something's wrong
yeah neighbors are just you know i'm
worried about the neighbors
or yeah yeah one time i think one of the
neighbors came out with his kids because
it was just like
sounded like it sounded full auto but it
was just like
four people just shooting at the same
time well there's that should be like
there's places in west virginia where
you where you can do that um
some of the training i did uh when i was
still in the intelligence community we
did out in
a spot in west virginia that where they
were able to get
uh get licenses and permits to shoot we
shot some pretty fun stuff
oh yeah we just shot bmd a couple weeks
ago yeah there's a range in georgia
where you can shoot full auto cool it's
great
really expensive but it's great yeah
there's a there's a thing they do at uh
the
def con which is the convention where uh
like in the early days they go out into
the mojave
and they set up a bunch of guns and uh
when i went there several years ago
that was like eight years ago maybe now
this guy had a
like belt fed 762 i think and it was
like
you got to pay for the rounds yourself
and then have at it
so we had big boxes of you know belts
and it's like
m24 i don't know which one it was he had
like three different ones
and they were just like people were like
yeah
just it was it was it was awesome yeah
yeah we did um we did that this place
down uh with ashley sinclair and we were
outside
outside houston they call it hella bacon
um
where you can act you've you can
actually get permits to go up and do
this a company that runs it it's totally
not a commercial et cetera et cetera
but you um so they do one range day
where you can just i mean anything you
want to shoot
literally anything up to and including a
minigun rpg
oh yeah you can do an rpg no no no no no
come on
no no um and then the next day you get
up super early
in a helicopter they take you up to
shoot wild hogs yes
with full auto ar-15s and you're go
you're flying over the ranch and the
ranch just want you to kill
auto air fifteens modified or what uh
they're modified it's like fire
wow yeah is that just an m16 um
no no because they're still they're
still the compact they make right right
yeah a lot of people don't understand
how bad hogs are it's it's horrible so
the ranchers want you up there doing it
right this this is an invasive species
they are pests
uh they tear it up they you know they
kill
um they can go after you know livestock
and so but it's it's
it's wild and people don't realize the
culture difference because
on your way to these ranches you know
you're you're flying there
and you're up in the air above you know
i'm looking down like this there's a
town right below me right you know
and you know it's texas so you know you
you pop off there you're gonna start
shooting back
this is my thing on the great reset i'm
kind of like totally it's totally
different from
the east coast kind of mentality if if
uh if the great reset is limited to
if you if you live in big cities you eat
the bugs and live in the pod i'll be
like okay
like if you have a choice to live in
these awful places sure
whatever people can choose to do that
there are always going to be hogs to
hunt it is impossible to get rid of them
it's impossible to get rid of them on
them basically everywhere where they
exist
we were up there for hours and they just
kept coming yeah we just had we stopped
because we were running we were
running along fuel and we're like wow we
got flight out anybody who's familiar
with any kind of
mmorpg knows that you know there's hogs
they're just responding
that's how you level up yeah so i know
so my level i mean i came in pretty low
like i was like this level yeah as
much south park got this wrong you can't
just
kill hogs boars to level up because as
soon as
once you're a few levels above them you
stop getting experience for doing it you
were well rested though
so you got an xp bonus well yeah exactly
that's right
eventually gotta go for the most
dangerous good like the boss hog
the boss hog i gotta find the boss hawk
shot giant twenty-four
after so they had coyotes as well
hunting coyotes we had coyotes out there
as well yeah you know you know what they
need
wolves we can find them the issue is
that uh in a lot of places with wolves
being displaced
because they were a threat to us right
right and so they fled then you get
invasive species running rampant deer
population explodes
man people don't understand why uh you
hunt deer and they're in
these cities i'll put it this way i'd be
willing to bet let's do a study
that if you went to a city and asked
this question okay here's a question for
you jack
you see a butterfly caught in a spider's
web do you free it
me personally no why not um
because i know that that spider is going
to be there
it's going to then consume the butterfly
and
it's and all those other pests and gnats
and
i don't know if a spider would go after
a cicada but maybe right so so
the idea is a filtration system
especially right i'd be willing to bet
that if you go to a city
or if you go to like a liberal and ask
they'd free the butterfly whereas a
conservative wouldn't
because obviously we understand the
beauty of the butterfly i could be wrong
i could be totally wrong about this
maybe liberals are just ruthless
something like killing both or something
crazy
i don't really think that i think they
typically would be like the butterfly is
an important pollinator and it's
beautiful and a part of nature and it
shouldn't die to a spider spider can eat
anything else
and so a lot of conservatives will
probably just be like circle of life you
know the spider eats the bugs it's the
past butterfly or not
so that that's a difference in mentality
i think about
you know so we're city folk out here we
had a deer feeder and they were like oh
you're gonna kill some deer and we're
like nah
he's gonna feed him like why they're
pests no
they're like they're awful that's
exactly what it was like they over
populate
they destroy crops they destroy trees
they need to the copulation levels need
to be kept down otherwise they get
diseased and ridden with like
nasty parasites starved to death and so
they're like don't just feed them
and i'm like well the good news is they
don't like the deer feeder the birds do
oh my god the birds are fine
hey we had this growing up um valley
forge park was always
uh a huge place for us to go on weekends
ended up actually got engaged got
married right right near there
and um but because it's federal
protected it's feral park right national
park
um the deer know this and so they know
if they go
they go there right well they know that
like this is like a safe
area right so you get to the point where
i mean
when it's dusk you like can't drive
around right because the deer
are everywhere and they're tearing up
all this stuff and a lot of the land
right there that's
that's actual you know some of it it's
it's some of these dirt forts and
different fortifications that were made
by
the actual uh continental army under
george washington during that winter
um right so philadelphia has fallen the
british have taken it it's
a this is prior to the uh uh the
crossing of the delaware and the battle
trenton
and so or just before that i should say
and so
you know these deer are tearing up
actual u.s history
but you know and this is pennsylvania so
people are like
so can can we go after the deer please
and and the federal government had to do
this whole like permit system to let
people go in and then
hire guys from like the usda to come in
so there's actually like a deer death
squad
basically wow i believe it's under usda
from
like years ago and i'm like how do you
they're walking around armed
up for oh yeah which which department
are you with usda you step aside you're
just dear skipper
man step back uh i hope you're all
sitting down because it might infuriate
you but uh this morning
i saw a deer and it was eating our
mulberries what
don't worry it was bambi's mom
that's like simpsons uh don't don't let
their bovine nature
fool you given the chance a cow would
kill you and your entire
we have pawpaw trees out here do you
guys know what pawpaws are
they're like i guess they're like mango
and banana combined oh yeah yeah
it's like the only set fruit of that
type in north america or something so we
have this tree
and i remember seeing like the deer were
always crowding on our driveway because
there's a tree right there in you know
in august and september whatever all
these fruits are there
and they're like they're they're in the
middle of the road so no no for real
like when you're coming down at night
there's no street lights or anything
no no you got to be real careful and
then you see them standing they're
really
dumb yep they just like they'll walk up
to the car just stare at you as you're
like heading like what's this i'm like
yeah like we talk about darwin awards
but no really
there's just too many of them we got
turkeys too we got a lot of turkeys
yeah i've seen them walking around in
the woods dude yeah yeah they're getting
up on you they're around you're like
yeah they walk up to that push and
you're like oh
i was unprepared for how well you gobble
no but it's the same thing when you when
you talk to people out here they're like
turkeys huh we can we can help you out
with that and i'm like what's the
problem
they're like turkeys are pests like you
gotta get rid of them they're like
turkeys are bad people tim
you don't understand then like they like
a video of church
turkeys are just spray painting and
vancouver like it's like the beginning
of one of those cop shows and you see
that yeah yeah it's the turkeys of
course it was the turkeys he just like
sniffed
dude well this was someone saw a
mountain lion out here
yeah outward really yeah like really
really yeah
yeah which is i don't know why it's rare
it happens yeah but we were told that on
this side of the river because
because uh if you guys have ever played
any mmorpg you know that certain mobs
can only spawn
on certain sides of the river like if
you're in zones yeah like if you're an
elwin forest you know that the the bores
and the nulls
don't spawn and darkshire and the ghouls
don't spawn in elwin
so uh across the river from us there's
like bears and it's like way more
serious because it's west virginia but
in the maryland side
they're like you don't got to worry
about anything like deer it's like
really low level stuff
but every so often a bear or a bobcat or
a mountain lion will be spotted and so
people are saying like
not too far from here in this area in
western maryland they spotted a
like a mountain lion or whatever so
they're like you got to be careful now
think about that
you live out one of these houses you get
an alert you see unfaithful like guys we
got a report from the local authorities
there's a mountain lion spotted in the
area
please be armed and safe think about
that please be
armed and safe yeah and now you get
these laws
15 come on man nobody need 15 you know
10
rounds and then people are like if you
can't hit it in 10 rounds you shouldn't
be shooting at it
oh okay so i'm not a professional i'm
not a professional
military man or law enforcement guy but
i want to keep my friends and family
safe from a mountain lion
and if it takes me more look maybe i'm
really bad
and i'm like trying to protect myself
from a mountain lion
yeah maybe i need to have a standard
capacity magazine of 30 rounds
if you're not a marksman your whole
family should die if someone breaks in
that's right yeah a mountain lion breaks
given that situation
i mean you know i i i i have a military
background but i i've never considered
myself to be like
you know like there's certain i don't
know like as you come influencers
pundits out there that are like really
focused on second amendment
and shooting and like that's their whole
thing i love them they're great guys
i've always been more like the current
events breaking news kind of guy
but just to you know defend the ar-15
for a second right
that you're talking about a firearms
platform
where the reason so many people use it
is because it is versatile and because
it is something that has a great
accuracy for someone who is a hobbyist
for someone who
is you know just getting kind of getting
into guns
that you're going to have a better um
propensity for actually hitting your
target rather than you're using like
like a glock or a 45 or any nine
millimeter any handgun
right certainly at a greater distance
right you are going to
put your rounds on target in a safer
more controlled
um situation with an ar-15 than you
would with almost
any other firearm out there speaking
generally thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you